a tough time to be a Democrat that's the
subject of tonight's waters words
tonight Saturday February 22nd there's
no fake scandal hanging over Donald
Trump's head right now
Bloomberg he blew it and a grumpy gray
socialist is racing towards the
nomination collusion failed impeachment
failed so Democrats have to face Trump
at the ballot box Democrats know they
can't beat him so they tried to get an
old rich Republican to do it but
Bloomberg choked he paid four hundred
million dollars to get a beat down now
maybe he's into that kind of thing I
don't know that's none of my business
but that was brutal
and now he's getting clowned on the
Democratic presidential debate
[Music]
[Applause]
the stage is narrowed to six candidates
and there's a new person on the stage
tonight Mayor Michael Bloomberg a former
Republican who spent millions of his own
dollars to run in this race hasn't
changed majority of Democratic voters
still say their top priority is beating
president Truong Mike got pummeled and
it wasn't pretty
he just doesn't have what it takes and
he looked like a mummy up there I'd like
to talk about who were running against a
billionaire who calls women fat broads
and horse-faced lesbians and no I'm not
talking about Donald Trump I'm talking
about Mayor Bloomberg the mayor said
when we passed it the signature piece of
this administration it's a disgrace
they're the exact words it was a
disgrace look it up mr. Bloomberg had
policies in New York City of
stop-and-frisk which went after
african-american and Latino people in an
outrageous way that is not a way you're
going to grow voter turnout Mike was
flattened and so is the media it's
difficult to spin a debate so we got the
truth look the real winner in the debate
last night was Donald Trump
well I still had the person who won the
debate last night whose name is Donald
Trump Donald Trump will destroy Michael
Bloomberg if last night is any example I
thought it was a great night for Donald
Trump I thought it was a terrible night
for the Democrats I don't think anybody
tonight convinced me they could win
Trump won every Democrat debate the
Democrats are basically just picking who
they're going to lose with but the
internet never loses
[Applause]
watch your watch your name the president
delivered some color commentary on what
went down in Vegas many Mike didn't do
well last night I was gonna send him a
note saying it's not easy doing what I
do is it
how about Klobuchar did you see her she
choked she choked Alfred he Newman
looked at her and said something
slightly derogatory and she said are you
accusing me of being dumb who would make
a statement like that that was the end
of her campaign in my book forgiving how
about sleepy Joe how about his
performance what what it's great to be
it's great to be with the great people
of Ohio
Joe Joe you're in Iowa you're an island
oh he did it five times but you're gonna
vote for one of these people probably
crazy Bernie he seems to be leading
now besides landing body bows like that
Trump's got the power of the presidency
all behind him he touched down at the
Daytona 500 and Air Force one amazing
spectacle drives the presidential
limousine they call it the Beast around
the track and then he started the race
himself Daytona International Speedway
we love our country and it's truly an
honor to be with all of you at the great
American race gentlemen start your
engines the majesty of moments like this
plus the red-hot economy Trump's fat
warchest his sharp tongue it's gonna
make him hard to beat Bernie Sanders is
a long shot half the Democratic Party
hates him because he's not even a
Democrat but he's surging because his
troops are on a mission Sanders and the
Bernie bros they can't be controlled
they're our threat to powerful people so
powerful people are now fighting back
from the shadows
the CIA briefed Bernie last month that
the Russians are trying to boost his
campaign then the CIA leaked the
briefing yesterday to the Washington
Post the day before Nevada
Bernie wasn't happy how did he think it
came out now if you had the briefing a
month ago well let you guess about one
day before the Iowa the Nevada caucus
why do you think that came out was the
Washington Post good friends snakes in
the Intel agencies are doing Bernie
dirty just like they did Trump muddy
them up with these Russian rumors and
make them look suspicious at least they
briefed Bernie instead of wiretapping
I'm like they did with Trump
we'll see if Bernie can handle the heat